CATHERINE ARMATO: Hi.
JONO GRANT: Hello.
It's like "Pigs in Space."
CATHERINE ARMATO:
So I just wanted
to thank you guys so
much for coming today.
We're really excited to have
you here at Google, and here
in New York City.
You just announced your new
album, "We Are All We Need."
And I was wondering
if you could tell
us more about what we
can expect from it?
JONO GRANT: Did you see that?
TONY MCGUINNESS: It's is a
mixture of reggaeton and trap.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: Why
are you laughing?
TONY MCGUINNESS:
It's the most tracks
we've ever put on an album.
16 tracks.
Features collaborations
with Justine Suissa,
of OceanLab fame, you will know.
Zoe Johnston.
And Alex Vargas.
In terms of the subject
matter, I think the title,
"We Are All We Need,"
comes from a song
that Zoe wrote that's
on the album called
"We Are All We Need," which I
believe premieres this week.
JONO GRANT: Times
Square, 7:00 PM.
TONY MCGUINNESS: And
it sort of suggests
a kind of mutual
self-reliance that's
a theme that comes up
a lot on the album.
So if it was appropriate
to call it that.
It feels like a development
from "Group Therapy."
It's about what you can
achieve with other people.
And it feels like a very
Above and Beyond thing
to say as well.
Overcome emotionally.
CATHERINE ARMATO: You mentioned
that Alex, Justine, and Zoe
will all be featured
on the new album.
How do you go about finding
such amazing vocalists?
And how do you determine
which songs they'll sing on?
JONO GRANT: Well,
first of all, I
think tend to look for
people who haven't worked
with a lot of other
people in our area.
So rather than just get the
kind of off-the-shelf singer
of the moment who's had a
few hits with someone else,
we will try and
dig a bit deeper.
And maybe look outside of
the genre that we operate in.
So with Zoe, she had
worked with Faithless,
who do do dance music.
But she'd also why
worked with Bent as well,
who've done some amazing music.
So we just look for something
a little bit different, really.
And outside the usual
channels, if you like.
CATHERINE ARMATO: Tell us about
the journey to Madison Square
Garden.
What made you choose New York
as the ABGT100 celebration?
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: Well, obviously
we do one of these big shows
a year to celebrate
our radio show.
Last year was Alexandra
Palace in London.
Year before that we were
in Bangalore in India.
And so on.
Yeah, for us it really
felt like we really
wanted to do one in
America this year.
We'd already done LA.
Sp we thought, OK.
New York would be awesome.
But where?
And so we're thinking of
all these potential venues.
And then somebody
says, OK, yeah.
I think we can do
Madison Square Garden.
And we're like, no.
We can't do Madison
Square Garden.
It is not going to happen.
But really, it's been
quite the journey.
We were here in January.
We did a site visit
to have a look at it.
So ever since January,
it's been just planning.
Doing.
Making music.
Figuring out what we
want to do with the show.
Who should come with
us, and everything.
So it feels quite unreal
that just in two days
we'll actually
finally get to do it.
I'm just beyond excited.
A little nervous, but
that's always good.
It'll feel even better
when it goes all well.
JONO GRANT: Yeah.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: What a venue.
JONO GRANT: It's also
about-- I was going to say,
it's also about picking
those moments to make
a step up somewhere.
We felt the same when we did
Alexandra Palace in London.
When I moved to
London, I remember
seeing-- we went to a
gig at Alexandra Palace.
And I never dreamed
of playing there.
I mean, it's a huge venue.
And again, with
Madison-- I'd never
have dreamed of playing
at Madison Square Garden.
But this was the right time
for us to have a go at it.
And you know, the response,
with the ticket sales
and everything, was incredible.
CATHERINE ARMATO: How did you go
about choosing the artists that
are playing with
you on Saturday?
TONY MCGUINNESS: We
was trying to include
other artists on the label.
[CELL PHONE RINGS]
There's one of them
on the phone now.
They basically rang us up
like that, out of the blue.
And said, what are you
doing next Saturday?
No, we was trying to include
other artists on the label.
And we try and rotate those
year by year as much as we can,
to give everybody a chance of
appearing on these big shows.
And it's definitely
Ilan Bluestone's year.
He's done some incredible
work in the last 12 months.
Mat Zo goes from
strength to strength.
Andrew Bayer is an enormously
important part of the label
and of Above and Beyond.
So it sort of chose
itself this time.
CATHERINE ARMATO: So it
was really special for us
as fans to hear all of the songs
stripped down for acoustic.
I was wondering if
you could tell me more
what your experience was
like producing and performing
that album?
JONO GRANT: Yeah.
I mean, when-- it was
actually Tony's idea
to do an acoustic
project, if you like.
And I think both
myself and Paavo
were a little bit resistant
to the idea of it.
Because you're essentially
putting yourself
in the arena of other bands.
And saying, we're a band.
And up until that point,
what the public knew of us
was only our dance music.
And we do play instruments.
We always have done.
But it's not something
we've shown to the public.
So it was quite a
nerve-wracking thing to do.
But at the same
time, we're sort of
coming at it with a mildly
kind of blank canvas,
because no one's ever seen
us do that kind of a gig.
It could have ended up being
a really Spinal Tap disastrous
kind of thing.
And I think it
didn't, thankfully,
judging by all your
response to it.
But it was great fun.
Because when we were
doing the acoustic album,
we'd rock up to the
studio with Bob,
who is kind of the designated
producer and musical director
for the whole show, really.
And we'd play our parts--
piano, Rhodes, guitar.
And we were being
produced by Bob.
And so the tables
really were turned.
And you could actually
relax into it,
rather than sort of talking
over a talk-back mic to a singer
saying, can you sing
this a bit differently?
We were in that chair
playing our instruments.
And it was great having someone
else telling you, you're great.
Play it a bit more like that.
It was a great experience
end to end, wasn't it?
TONY MCGUINNESS:
Yeah, definitely.
CATHERINE ARMATO: And Tony,
this is a question more for you.
Will we hear any more
from Making Plans,
or was that strictly
an acoustic release?
TONY MCGUINNESS: It is on the
new album, I'm happy to say.
It was an interesting
one to try and produce
in a form that fit on the
album, because we wrote it
such a long time ago.
And it hasn't ended up the way
I imagined when we wrote it.
But it's amazing, I think.
JONO GRANT: It was in a really
difficult range, BPM-wise.
Sometimes you get a track
that is, say, around 65 BPM,
or something like that.
And you can kind of
double it up to 130ih.
It's just some tracks
just work at some tempos.
And that was one of the hardest
tracks to work at dance tempo,
wasn't it, really.
CATHERINE ARMATO: Paavo,
I saw some of the photos
that you posted at Burning Man.
I was wondering if
you guys could tell me
more about that experience?
And if you prepare for
those sets differently?
And if you got to experience
the festival at all?
PAAVO SILJAMAKI:
Well, obviously,
that was our first
time at Burning Man.
And it's one of those
festivals that we've always
really wanted to go to.
And we didn't quite know.
I think it's like
one of those things
that you can't really
describe even correctly.
You have to go there
and experience it.
But we did we did the
yoga sets with Elena,
who's actually from New York.
An amazing yogi?
At Robot Hut during sunset.
Which was a really interesting
set for us to play.
Because, obviously, we normally
don't play that chill music.
And, you know, I've
dabbled a little bit
with yoga myself over the years.
So I could kind of
imagine what might work.
[CELL PHONE RINGS]
JONO GRANT: That's Mat Zo.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: And do that.
Hey, Mat.
We also did a deep
set over there.
Not too unlike what we're
planning to do on Saturday.
We open the show.
So we had those opportunities
to do something really,
really different
from our normal gigs.
And then our gig at White
Ocean was really more
of a traditional
Above and Beyond gig.
Butt the audience was definitely
not the traditional audience.
It was such a mix of people.
Just wonderful, wonderful,
wonderful atmosphere
over there.
And I came out of Burning Man--
you know, I knew I'd be wowed.
But I came actually touched.
I was really touched seeing
the burning of embrace
as my last thing over there.
And really seeing how
Burning Man is really
about people doing really
cool things for each other.
And when you see people
doing really cool things
for each other, you want
to also do the same thing.
So I was kind of
thinking, one day,
maybe the world's going
to be like Burning Man.
And it'll be a good place.
CATHERINE ARMATO: That
would be pretty cool.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Would be.
There'd be a lot more
nudity, for a start.
Good thing.
CATHERINE ARMATO: In
addition to the deep set
you did at Burning
Man, you also released
an Anjuna Deep Editions set.
You remixed the set for
the Anjuna Deep Edition.
Do you think there'll be more
deep sound releases coming
from Above and Beyond, or
stick with the club sound?
TONY MCGUINNESS: Well, we
like playing deep music.
We just don't get much of
a chance to do it, really.
That's why Burning
Man was nice to do.
We played in Brazil a few
weeks ago at the World Cup,
and got away with
playing a deep house set.
It's just a nice and very
popular area of music
that we're kind of involved in.
And we just don't really
get a chance to do it.
So when we do get a chance
to do it, it's nice to do it.
Like Paavo said, we're
doing the warm-up
set for ABGT100, which
will be mostly Anjuna Deep.
One or two others.
And I would like to do more of
those when the occasion arises.
Obviously, for our
shows, for the most part,
people want to hear the Above
and Beyond songs and the vibe
that they know.
And whilst those things work
in a smaller environment--
on the tail end of a yoga
session or warming up for one
of our shows--
it's not something
we really get a
chance to do a lot.
But I would like to do it more.
I'm actually really interested
in all kinds of dance music.
We sort of make a living from
doing one particular bit of it.
But it would be nice
to have a broader
canvas, if we were
able to do that.
JONO GRANT: I think, yeah.
I have a feeling we might
end up doing what he said.
And doing a bit more of
that in the future, yeah.
CATHERINE ARMATO: We
had a lot of people
that were curious
where the names came
from on the new album cover.
Can you shed some light on that?
JONO GRANT: Well, we just
did a Google Hangout,
and we decided it was all smoke
and mirrors, really, didn't we?
But they came from social
media, essentially.
We'll leave it that.
CATHERINE ARMATO: OK.
TONY MCGUINNESS: We
don't really want
to say how we getting them.
Because then people,
if we say, actually,
we pick them up from Twitter
on Wednesday between 3:00
and 4:00, everybody's
going to start
tweeting between 3:00
and 4:00 on a Wednesday.
And it'll ruin it.
It's people who are actively
involved in our online family.
And "We Are All We Need"
includes all of you guys.
JONO GRANT: Is anyone
on the album cover here?
There you go.
TONY MCGUINNESS: We're trying
to include as many people
as we can on the artwork
through the campaign,
with all the single
sleeves as well.
But if you can't wait to
see yourself on there,
you can actually make
your own album artwork
with a bit of
software that we've
had designed that sticks
your name on right now.
Well, good.
CATHERINE ARMATO:
One of the ways
that you connect with
fans during your shows
is the messages that
you have you come up
on the screens behind you.
How did that start?
And are you typing those live?
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: Yeah.
That actually started
because we were bringing
a laptop to our gigs
anyway as a backup.
This is still when
we were playing CDs.
Just so you could burn a CD
if you're missing a track.
JONO GRANT: So he could
burn a CD, not us.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI:
Because it was there,
you'd have Photoshop
or Illustrator
for writing little messages.
JONO GRANT: So he could have
Photoshop or Illustrator.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: So, OK.
So then I decided to
write a little message.
Show the laptop to the people.
When we're in venues like
200 people, it's awesome.
Works great.
And suddenly felt like
we had this new means
of communicating with people.
Like, really directly, actually.
But then in 2010, we were
at ADC at the LA Coliseum,
and just holding up the laptop
to a little bit more than 150
people felt like it
didn't quite work.
So we're showing it to
the camera over there.
And they put it
up on the screen.
And we thought, hang on.
Maybe that's the
way we can do it.
JONO GRANT: So he went
off into a rabbit hole
and coded a system to
do that, didn't you?
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: I did.
Yeah, yeah.
I love technology.
And I've been always really
interested in the show,
and how this show can
be used to enhance
people's feeling of
connectedness to the music
and to each other.
And how we can use to enhance
the atmosphere of the event.
JONO GRANT: At this
point, I should point out
that Paavo actually
wrote a clocking system
to send the BPM of the decks
to our visual system as well.
And all sorts of stuff.
TONY MCGUINNESS:
That's only half of it.
JONO GRANT: That's
the minor thing.
TONY MCGUINNESS: We
discovered that the output
from the Pioneer mixer wasn't
high resolution enough.
So he got in touch with Pioneer.
And now it is.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: That's true.
But-- you I suppose we're at
Google, so it's all right.
CATHERINE ARMATO: Yeah.
I was actually going to ask next
how you guys have been using
technology to connect
with your fans.
Like, in addition to the
messages at your shows.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI:
Well, our first thing
was when we actually started.
Big record companies
were basically saying,
we don't do websites.
And internet was like
this sort of thing
that some young people
are doing somewhere.
But actually--
JONO GRANT: If you
did [INAUDIBLE].
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: The real
world doesn't interact with it.
But we really started
with the internet in mind.
And very early on, we
had an internet forum
that for us was the
first sort of step.
Hang on, we can actually
use the internet
to really get to know the
people that listen to our music,
and interact with them.
Then we saw the music as
a distribution platform
quite early on.
So we had a shop where we
were first selling music
with copyright protection.
Downloadable.
This is really a long time ago.
I can't believe we
even tried that.
JONO GRANT: I think we were
one of the first labels
to-- one of the first
independent labels, at least--
to do online distribution
of our music.
MP3 downloads, basically.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: And
this is a long time
before iTunes or Beatport.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Or
Google, actually.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: But yeah.
It's been amazing seeing
how the internet has really
grown from that kind of
almost underground movement
into something that everyone,
pretty much everyone
around the world, either
has something to do with,
or their lives are
definitely being
influenced by the internet.
And it's a tool for learning.
I think it's just
beyond amazing.
And I can't wait to
see what it leads to
over the next 25 years.
I personally use it
when I want to learn
how to be a better barista.
Google it.
It's a speedy learning tool.
It's incredible.
JONO GRANT: One
of the things, one
of the incredible things
I find now is on YouTube.
If you go onto
YouTube, and you want
to find out how a
particular track is made,
there are people
who've basically
dissected one of your tracks.
And recreated the whole
record in Fruity Loops
or Keybase or Logic.
I just find that mind-blowing.
Because when I was growing
up with learning about music
production, I would
learn everything
from magazines and
from my own experience.
And now this is wealth
of knowledge on YouTube.
Where if you don't know how
to make a certain white noise
sweep, you'll find
it on YouTube.
I think that's just
amazing, you know?
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: Where
I think social media
these days is really that
the genuinely amazing things
that people see and
feel like one to share.
Those are the
things really work.
And that would work
in this room as well.
If somebody sees
something really amazing,
they're probably going
to tell someone else.
And so it spreads.
So I think there's so
much concentration--
how can we use social
media in the best way?
And how do we know what
the best techniques?
And what's the
new silver bullet?
But I think what
we've taken from all
of this is that if we really
concentrate on the core of what
we do-- we try make the
best songs that we can,
and give people the most
amazing experiences at the shows
and online-- then, hopefully,
they'll tell others.
And so it works.
At least, that's the theory.
JONO GRANT: That's a
really important point.
Because I think there's
a big attraction
to the social media
side of things.
But actually, in a
cold-hearted business sense,
the product is the music.
And you've got to
put that first,
and not the social media.
The social media is very
much a secondary thing.
If you make a great
record, that will blow away
a million tweets.
It's really important.
Because I see a lot of
kids getting into it,
and kind of believing
it's really important
to have a great
social media presence.
But that can be
dealt with, I think,
by good management and
a good team around you.
Whereas having the right ideas
to make the right records,
that's the most important thing.
That's the core.
CATHERINE ARMATO: In
just a few minutes,
we'll be taking questions
from the audience.
So if you guys have
questions, please line up
at one of the microphones
on either side of the room.
TONY MCGUINNESS: And if
you can't think of one,
you can phone a friend.
CATHERINE ARMATO: So I'm
a huge "Breaking Bad" fan.
I wanted to hear the story
behind the creation of "Walter
White."
And what your favorite
"Breaking Bad" episode is.
JONO GRANT: Well,
that track-- and I'd
be lying if I said we came
up with the idea of doing
a "Breaking Bad" track,
OK, first of all.
But as we were
making the track, we
realized that it had
a split personality.
There's a very dark, clubby
kind of intro and outro
to the track, with
a kind of uplifting
break down the middle.
And Walter White, he's
a very two-sided--
or, well, maybe more than
two sides to his character.
So it just felt like the
right time, the right name.
It was just one of those
things-- of course,
we'll call it Walter White.
It just felt right.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI:
There's a new track
called "Saul" on the new one.
JONO GRANT: No.
That might be a joke track.
CATHERINE ARMATO: I'd be excited
to hear what that sounds like.
OK.
We're going to take our
first audience question now.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JONO GRANT: Hello.
AUDIENCE: My name is Naomi.
So, your music is like, really
emotional, and, like, really
inspirational to me, and I
bet a lot of other people
in this room.
And inspired me to get
a sun and moon tattoo.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Wow.
AUDIENCE: So I just wanted to
know, what inspires you guys?
TONY MCGUINNESS: So
much inspires me.
I went to see a film
last night that I
didn't know anything about.
I came away-- I mean, I was
close to tears at the end.
It's called "The
Skeleton Twins."
And I come away from
experiences like that,
or reading great book, or
hearing a great record.
And it lives with
me for a long time.
And little bits go in.
When you come to write songs,
ideas that you've heard,
and experience from other
media, really are important.
I think no input,
no output, really.
So everything that we see
and experience in our lives.
Everything that
we read in books.
Every record that we hear,
every film that we see,
goes in somewhere and
comes out eventually.
So many things, I
think, especially now.
The way that YouTube
and on-demand TV are.
We can really feast on
things that we like.
And I think, if we had the time,
we could spend all our times,
all our lives, watching TV.
But there's so much
great stuff out there.
I think we're getting--
I saw loads of trailers
before the film started.
It feels like we're
getting into Oscar season
again, because they were like,
yeah, I want to see that one.
Yeah, I want to see that one.
It's great.
I think there's some
incredible stuff.
They made so much
music that's around
at the moment to
get inspired by.
With our Kindles, we can
read books all the time.
It's just great, I
think, at the moment.
[INAUDIBLE]
PAAVO SILJAMAKI:
For me, at least,
the moments where I've
felt really inspired
is often when I feel
like I can connect
with a sort of
emotional state that I
can remember from
having experienced.
So be, like, utter happiness
and joy, or a really sad moment,
or something like that.
The way I write a lot
is playing the piano.
So if I'm playing the
piano, I can really
get into that emotional state.
And often I then
find that really
helps to feel really inspired.
And the nice thing
with being creative
is you can't really plan it.
You can't really
go into something
knowing what's going to
come out at the other end.
I love the journey
of getting there.
And that's why making
music is so cool.
JONO GRANT: I think one of the
most amazing things about music
is-- so, drawing from that--
when you are in a state
and you write something,
and someone else
can listen to that
piece of music
and be taken to that place.
That's just the most
incredible thing.
Because it's not something
that we're taught at school,
how to interpret music.
But it's a kind of universal,
world-wide language.
And I can't think of anything
else that is quite like that,
really.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: Thank you.
JONO GRANT: Thank you.
CATHERINE ARMATO: I'll
take a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Jesus.
I DJ in my free time.
And some of my DJ
sets that I recorded
live, I uploaded
them to Some Cloud.
And they were
flagged because they
contain copyrighted
material, obviously.
So my question is,
like, what do you
think about the
situation in copyright
that we are living in?
Should the users of your music
be punished for sharing them?
Or should be increased
to share them
so that they can go
to your concerts?
And do you think that
sharing live mixes and DJ
sets has helped you or
has hurt your career?
JONO GRANT: It's a really
difficult question to answer,
because if we weren't able
to perform and do gigs,
we wouldn't be able
to do this job.
Because we earn a living
from performing shows.
People who make music full
time really struggle-- really,
really, struggle-- to
earn a living from that.
It's a question I've
struggled to answer, really,
because I have so many
mixed feelings about it.
When U2 gave away an album--
I'm sure they got paid for it,
right?-- but it's
great promotion.
I mean when Radiohead, they
released an album a long time
ago, and invited fans to
pay what they wanted for it.
And that's fine for
Radiohead to do that,
because they're such a big band.
They don't need to worry
about the royalties
that they'll earn from that
particular record as much.
However, it does set a
precedent for everyone
in the music industry
to some degree.
And then to try and
meet that precedent
if you're a smaller
artist is challenging.
And what do you do?
Because if we said that, we'd be
all right, because we do shows.
But on the other hand,
a really small artist
who's up and coming, maybe
it would be a great success.
And maybe people would
pay lots for the album.
But I just feel like when you
devalue music in such a way,
it really does restrict
it to those artists who
are able to go out
and perform live.
And not everybody
is a performer.
Not everybody is a DJ.
Not everybody can go and
stand in front of 1,000 people
and do a convincing performance.
But there are a lot of people
who can make a great record,
as well.
So my question back to
anyone is, how do we--
should we-- make those people
included in the music industry
still?
Because that's a real
challenge, isn't it?
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: But as
it seems at the moment,
the future of music
distribution is streaming in
all its many forms.
And maybe some that
haven't yet been invented.
And I think that is pretty
much-- it's a compromise.
Subscription models
and streaming.
But I think that way, people
can do what they want to do.
Which is they can share music.
They can listen to
whatever they want.
And the musicians
still at the other end
should get some royalties.
Maybe not enough for to
do as a full-time job.
JONO GRANT: I think
you've hit on it there.
Because I think the
answer really is,
you shouldn't have to
have your mix taken down,
but the royalties
need to be tracked
so that someone gets paid.
That's I think a fair
answer to it, really.
I think you should be
allowed to put your mix up.
But, yeah.
Those records need
to be accounted
for by SoundCloud or something.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: But the
internet and music distribution
through the internet has vastly
helped us around the world.
That is how most of
our fans have first
heard our music-- somehow,
by the internet, I think.
And I think it will
continue to do that.
And even better than at
the moment, I believe.
Because more people are
getting online every day.
And there's so much interest
for electronic music
around the world.
And it's still brand-new
in so many countries.
So it's very exciting times.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name is Jude.
So obviously, I have a
like for British bands.
And my question
is, for vocalists,
like with "We Are All We
Need" and "Sun and Moon"
and all that stuff, do you--
they write their own lyrics,
right?
So do you tell
them, like, this is
the kind of vibe
we're going through?
Do you make any bit of
the song first and then
work with each other?
TONY MCGUINNESS: It depends.
It depends on who we're working
with and what the song is.
In the case of "Sun and Moon,"
for example, we wrote that.
JONO GRANT: With
TONY MCGUINNESS: And then
we got-- with Justine, yeah.
And we got Richard
to sing that for us.
And he sang the lyrics that
had already been written.
When we write with Justine, she
often writes most of her songs.
Same with Zoe.
It really depends on
the track in question.
AUDIENCE: So let's say they
wrote one of their lyrics,
or whatnot.
How do you go about
putting it all together
into a song where
everything sounds good?
Do you have a tune?
Or do you let them write
a song, and then think,
this melody will sound
great with these vocals,
or vice versa?
TONY MCGUINNESS: We tend to
write the song with them.
So the two things are
happening at the same time.
AUDIENCE: Gotcha.
Well, all right.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, I
want to thank you
guys for helping me get my
job done, because I listen
to your podcast for
four hours every day.
My question is--
JONO GRANT: Thanks
for giving us a job.
And
AUDIENCE: I'll see you
at your show on Saturday.
The question is, there's
a lot of collaboration
in the EDM music industry.
And can you tell
me more about that?
Because compared to
other genres of music,
EDM's always like,
one form, one artist
is mixing off some
other artist, who
is mixing off another artist.
And you get several of
them coming together.
And it's an unusually strong
form of collaboration.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: I think with
electronic music, obviously,
most of the music is, first of
all, produced electronically.
So it's easier for
people to collaborate,
even if they're not
in the same place.
Because obviously if you're
playing live instruments,
you really have to play
in the same room together
to really get into
that vibe together.
And also, dance music has
a long history of remixing.
So we started as remixers.
And so many people are used to
remixing other people's stuff.
So it's just a
tradition, I think.
There's a lot of
collaboration all throughout
the electronic music community.
JONO GRANT: Also, I think,
generally, people work better
in teams than they do alone.
I think that's a fair comment.
And it's true of
the music industry.
You look at an album like
"Dark Side of the Moon,"
and, again, it comes back
to that musical investment
question.
Because I'm not sure if that
album could be made easily
today, because of the
amount of people involved
and the amount of money
invested in a record like that.
It's a really cool thing when
great people get together--
a great engineer, great band.
And I think some of
the best dance records
are being made that way,
where you have a great singe.
Maybe two great producers.
And maybe someone else
it mixes the record.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Camille.
I just had a question.
At Trance Around the
World 350, you guys
debuted "Sun and Moon,"
and asked the crowd
to name the song.
Will you guys be doing the
same thing this Saturday
with your new album coming out?
JONO GRANT: Was
it "Sun and Moon?"
I think it was-- wasn't
it a different track?
AUDIENCE: I remember
"Sun and Moon."
People were yelling
TONY MCGUINNESS: No.
Because people already know
it's called "Sun and Moon."
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But will you
be debuting a new song
and asking the crowd
to name the track?
TONY MCGUINNESS: No.
I don't think we're going
to be doing a name the song.
We've kind of named
them all this time.
AUDIENCE: Sad.
Dang.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Yeah, we got
round to doing it this time.
So yes, there won't be a naming
this song section, I'm afraid.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sounds good.
TONY MCGUINNESS: OK.
AUDIENCE: Thanks,
CATHERINE ARMATO: Got
a question over here.
JONO GRANT: Over
to the east wing.
AUDIENCE: Hey, guys.
Thanks for stopping by.
It means a lot to us.
I'm curious about your
music creation process.
I know it's probably different
for every specific song.
But my specific
question is, who do you
think about when
you're writing songs?
Or rather, who do you write for?
I know some artists that
write mainly for themselves,
and some artists who
think about others
who'd be great to
play at a show.
I mean, even writing a song for
a fan to listen to at a show
is very different than
writing a song for someone
to listen to by themself
in their bedroom.
So I'm just curious
about is there
a general trend or
general direction
that you usually think about
when you're writing a song?
JONO GRANT: I think from a
musical perspective, rather
than the lyrical
perspective, for me,
it's definitely
writing for myself,
in terms of whatever
ideas spring to mind.
And then afterwards, during
the production phase,
you may produce--
obviously, you've
got certain formats
to think about.
Like a radio mix, or
something like that.
But I actually think it's
kind of really important,
if you're going to
move things forward,
you kind of need to do
what you believe in most.
And I think lyrically, it's
a similar thing, isn't it?
You don't think, oh, I'll
write this song because they're
going to sing along to it.
TONY MCGUINNESS: I
mean, I tried that.
Well, we tried it
once, I remember.
A long time ago with OceanLab,
with "Beautiful Together."
That was a song that
we decided to write
for a specific purpose.
And I don't think
it's that's good.
I think it's a lot healthier and
a lot easier-- I mean, it's OK.
But it's not-- to me, it
wasn't-- I can see through it,
I guess.
It's difficult for
me to listen to it.
JONO GRANT: I think once
you've written it, you--
TONY MCGUINNESS:
But I think it's
about it's a lot easier
and a lot more meaningful
to write from the heart.
So you write-- as Jono said--
predominantly for yourself.
These are things that you
feel like you've got to say.
And then when you're in the
process of thinking what
songs might make the album,
how they'll be produced,
and maybe you're
thinking about how
they might transpose
to somebody else.
But the moment of creation,
it's a very personal thing,
actually, I think.
JONO GRANT: But
I think there are
sort of two phases to writing.
The one where you have
the original idea.
And that's the most organic bit.
And then there's the moment when
you take a step back from it.
And you hone that idea.
And I suppose that is more the
contrived side of it, that bit.
It's more considered,
and less of what
Paavo was talking about earlier,
when you're just getting on
with it and it's flowing.
You do sit back.
And you go, well, hang on a sec.
This song's 12 minutes long.
That isn't going to work.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: Yeah.
And the real art of production
and great production
is doing all the analytical
stuff without killing the song.
And we sometimes
started from something
we felt like has an
incredible core, produced it,
and then we lost something.
We went back.
Tried it again.
And three years later,
we've got "Sun and Moon."
JONO GRANT: Yeah, "Sun and
Moon" is living proof for us
that you can work on about
50 versions of the song
and sort of get it right.
Because sometimes you think
if you overwork something,
it's going to make it worse.
And it does make it worse.
And sometimes you have to
leave it for next album.
We've got songs we've written
for this album that didn't make
it on that we'll revisit,
I'm sure, in future years.
And "Sun and Moon"
was one of those.
It was supposed to be
on the OceanLab album.
As was "Thing Called
Love," actually, wasn't it?
But those songs wouldn't have
been as good as they are,
perhaps-- or certainly
not how they've ended up--
if we hadn't have left
them and come back to them.
They would have been on
there, but maybe-- maybe they
would have been even better.
Dunno.
Can't say.
But we had a lot of versions
we weren't happy with,
is what I can say.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
CATHERINE ARMATO: We have
time for one more question.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Awww.
AUDIENCE: I'm lucky.
Hi.
My name's Jeff.
My favorite song right now
is Ilan Bluestone's remix
of "Satellite."
So I'm wondering what
your favorite remix
or mash-up of your own song is.
TONY MCGUINNESS: My
favorite remix of our songs
is the Seven Lions remix
of "On My Way to Heaven,"
because-- it's a weird
thing, because obviously, I
don't think I'd ever heard
anything like the kind of music
that he makes when
we wrote the song.
And the one issue that
they raise with the song
is it's not a very traditional
song structure tool.
It goes through
various different bits.
And suddenly, here was
this kind of music form
where in the space
of five minutes,
you could have seven
different themes and vibes.
And it just-- everything
works so well.
It's great.
I love it.
JONO GRANT: I couldn't
pick one, to be honest.
But I agree with you, that
was a fantastic remix.
When we did a remix
competition, people
think-- I think
people think-- we're
going to pick something that
sounds like what people think
Anjuna Beats is
about at the time.
changing all the time.
It might be something different
tomorrow, next week, next year.
But that remix just popped out.
It wasn't what we
expected to get.
But it was just
incredible, wasn't it?
TONY MCGUINNESS:
Yeah, it was amazing.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: And I
remember you guys did
the Stereosonic
tour in Australia.
And I was tuning
into it live when
you were on stage in Sydney.
And I heard the "You Got
to Go" and Believe in Me"
bootleg for the first time.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Oh, yeah.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI:
I was like, what?
Hey, that's brilliant.
I didn't know it was
happening, but you guys
were preparing all that
stuff for that tour.
And it's been interesting.
Because obviously, sometimes
remixes are really interesting,
because somebody's really,
like, actually built a new thing
around the core of the song.
Bootlegs can also be
really interesting,
where sometimes when
you match up vocal
from another and instrument
from another, somehow
they make more sense
out of both of them.
And that was the
case with those two.
TONY MCGUINNESS: And on a good
day, the "Metropolis" mix.
I mean, it's uncanny--
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: [INAUDIBLE].
TONY MCGUINNESS: --how
those things work together.
JONO GRANT: Artie
actually wanted
to put a vocal on "Believe
in Me," didn't he?
He kept on sending
us these vocals.
And we weren't
quite sure if he'd
got the right one at the time.
And then, so, when putting those
two tracks together, kind of
solved the problem for
him, I think, as well.
AUDIENCE: It's a great name,
too-- "You Got to Believe."
TONY MCGUINNESS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thank you.
JONO GRANT: You have to.
You got to believe.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Sorry about
that, west wing, east wing.
JONO GRANT: Oh, go on.
Let him--
TONY MCGUINNESS: Go on, quick.
Quick question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned a
bit about genres.
About how you were
noticing how genres
are changing and
becoming more popular.
I was curious about
what your thoughts
of how electronic music has
grown, and where it's going.
And what sort of
genres you might
be interested in
looking towards.
And how that influences the
way you make your music.
PAAVO SILJAMAKI: I realize
that maybe like 10 years ago,
we played a lot of places
that had a real genre tack.
We played a lot of trance
clubs, for example.
And what's happened, because
largely down to the internet,
is that a lot of the
electronic parties
happen in venues that
don't have a genre tack.
You might get a bit of
dubstep, and a bit of house,
and a bit of trance.
And at the moment,
I feel like we
live in a kind of
genreless place, in a way.
And I find it's
very interesting.
When people are
going to the studio,
there's less people
thinking of, you know,
today I'm going to make
a music in this genre,
and more people going
into the studio saying,
I'm going to make a track that's
going to be great for my sets
next weekend.
And it's that kind of
freedom of restriction
that's made music
really interesting.
And future is a little bit--
you know, it's not written.
We don't know where
it's going to lead.
But it's exciting.
JONO GRANT: Genre is a useful
labels for the press, I guess.
But I view genre as
like race, or religion,
or any of those things.
And I'm a proponent
of secularism.
So genre is kind of p-ing
me off a bit, really.
I mean, I just like music.
And the press can label us
or anybody what they want.
TONY MCGUINNESS: It's
exactly that, actually.
This may be--
JONO GRANT: Divisive.
TONY MCGUINNESS: But
the important thing,
I think, about the way it works
in the way that make people
make tracks, is they
bits of loads of genres.
If there was an app like
Shazam that sort of told you
what genre it was.
I always feel like this when
I'm listening to something--
is this tech house or techno?
I sort of feel like
I want to know,
because I want to appear
knowledgeable about it.
But if there was an
app that told you
what it was, it wouldn't
say, it's techno.
It would say, it's
got 20% of techno.
It's got 5% of dubstep.
It's got 20% of trance.
That's the nature of
electronic music, actually.
It isn't one genre.
We're not one race.
We're loads of different
ones, all mixed together.
And I think that's
what makes it great.
JONO GRANT: And as an artist,
you can't own a genre.
But you can own your
own artist name.
So with rock bands-- OK,
I've just mentioned a genre--
but rock is, I think, a lot
looser genre, in the same way
that you could say dance
music, for example.
You can own your own kind
of brand in that respect.
But Trance Around the World, we
can't own the genre of trance,
if trance goes in a direction
that we don't like, with Trance
Around the World, for example.
So by being Group
Therapy in that instance,
we're able to create above
and beyond world, rather
than clinging onto a genre
that's slipping away somewhere
we don't want it to go.
CATHERINE ARMATO: OK.
We're out of time.
I just want to thank you
guys so much for coming.
TONY MCGUINNESS: Thank you.
JONO GRANT: Thank you.